hey youtubers its charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 16 video
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet they did a big bad reveal I
mean we already knew who the Big Bad was
but they just lately actually showed his
face if you haven't read the secret
Warriors comic books they're doing a lot
of things from that they're pulling a
lot of characters but the storyline
isn't exactly the same even the hive
character in the comics is a little bit
different from what the TV show is doing
with them and even though I call him
hive his name is the hive so there's a
few distinctions between the way the
comic books use them in the way the TV
shows using him like on the TV show he
has all those tiny organisms that are
really like parts of himself that he
uses to devour people but in the comics
they're way way bigger but it's pretty
much the same thing he uses those
organisms to control other people that's
why he was taking out the bases where
they were developing technology to
counteract stuff like that so let's just
do top 5 WTF and I'll try to explain all
the craziness from the comic books
number 5
Daisy finds out that Lincoln killed his
last girlfriend the way they explain it
is that all that drama went down before
he took in the Terrigen mists he's been
trying to reform himself since then but
it kind of explains why his character
has been so standoffish like he's one of
the least charismatic characters on the
show right now I can understand why
female Watchers might really like him
you know he's kind of like the Winter
Soldier the broken puppy that you want
to nurse back to health but really for
me the most interesting part of that
storyline was them finding number 4 WTF
the orb that will probably have
something to do with banishing hive
again now notice that they said in the
past that hive one of the original
Inhumans that were created by the Kree
had to be banished they couldn't kill
him like you kill part of him there's
still thousands of tiny little organisms
that make up his body they could just go
off and inhabit someone else so we could
talk about that as we get closer to the
end of the season because in the comics
when the hosts that the hive is
inhabiting dies HSN habits another body
and it becomes Madame Hydra and she has
like this big tentacle looking hat that
she wears around all the time
so maybe that's what's gonna happen at
the end of the season I don't really
know if they'd be able to do that
without getting rid of grant Ward if he
even exists now number 3 WTF Malick's
Paradise Lost flashbacks this was so
much fun
I loved the way they brought back
Whitehall for that flashback scene so we
learned Malick is a complicated guy like
he started he was the one in the
flashbacks who was really upset that
they were even less
to Whitehall he was all about family
tradition he was his brother that ended
up getting sacrificed eventually he was
the one who was like I had to know what
our Father did he was a coward he was a
liar the whole time the irony is is that
Malik then uses their father's trick to
try and survive now he didn't want his
brother to get sacrificed it just worked
out that they were standing next to each
other and he got the short end of the
stick but as we find out his memories
were still alive inside hive so they
have the nice Paradise Lost middle
finger like his brothers giving him the
middle finger from beyond the grave
like I know what you did number
two WTF killing Malik's daughter I
actually thought that he was just gonna
turn her and she was just gonna be some
zombie for him for the rest of the
series this is a little bit better she
wasn't that big of a character so the
WTF of her die
wasn't quite as big as it could have
been we've really only met her for a
little while but here's what they're
doing you know number one WTF Malik is
now auntie hive he will probably try to
find a way to help Coulson by the end of
the series because as evil as he's been
he's a saint compared to what high-fives
planned for the earth and I love the way
they characterized this ancient inhuman
there were a couple different storylines
that were explaining hives backstory
namely through the Daisy Lincoln stuff
so what happened is is the Kree created
the Inhumans to fight in the kree-skrull
war they were gonna be their minions
hive was meant to lead that army
that's why his ability allows him to
control others to influence others so
that he could use them all like finger
puppets so it sounds like he's going to
be doing that before the end of the
season no matter what you get some big
spectacular inhuman seat where he's
controlling a bunch of people maybe some
people we know will end up getting
mind-controlled like Daisy and Lincoln
but even if you haven't read the comics
they kind of explained on the TV series
that the Kree abandoned the inhuman
project they're just like okay you know
this isn't working out the way we wanted
to so we're gonna pack up and leave in
the Inhumans that they created that
first generation had to figure out what
to do after that
but because hive was out of control they
all had a band together to banish into
that foreign planet ma-vess probably
using that orb which is Kree technology
so you can kind of see where the season
is going Daisy's like hey we have the
secret warriors team that we were
putting together
why don't we activate them they'll have
to band together again to find a way to
banish hive I feel like it's going to be
the situation where they'll never be
able to kill hive they'll only be able
to contain him or
banish him somewhere else but let me
know in the comments what do you think
is gonna happen with hive and with ward
at the end of the season do you think
that they're gonna have to get rid of
Brett Dalton they're gonna try and
banish hive to another planet or do you
think that hive is just gonna slink off
and habit someone else's body and come
back in a future season but if you guys
didn't see they've been talking a lot
about movie TV crossovers lately
even though agents of shield is gonna
have some Civil War stuff going on it's
gonna be a one way crossover Kevin Feige
actually clarified that because they
planned the movies so far in advance
most of the phase 3 movies had been
written and planned out before they ever
did Inhumans on agents of show up so
there's not really an easy way for them
to cross over logistically but that
doesn't mean that the TV shows will
never cross over with the movies it's
just that most of the crossover stuff
you see happening is gonna only be
addressed on the TV show the movies will
never address the TV shows so it's kind
of a bummer but now you understand why
DC was the same thing with their movies
and TV shows sort of like it's too
complicated so we're not even gonna try
we got our movies doing their thing we
got the TV shows doing their own thing
but I know there's some stuff that's
still on break this week like there's no
flash episode I will do a bonus video
for that because the actor that plays
zoom was talking about the man in the
metal mask in the finale so all kinds of
awesome stuff happening this week even
though there's some TV shows on break so
be sure to subscribe to get everything
and I will be doing some more Doctor
Strange later this week - why you guys
wait for me to post that next video you
can click here to learn all about the
spider-man homecoming movie and you can
click here to watch the Doctor Strange
trailer again thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you